girl hello come on let's go sit
somewhere we can all sit together you
guys
I just gotta put something in my mouth
I'm so hungry
I figured two people can sit on each
chair you guys
there are some leftovers for us here
let's have a couple of leftovers and
then we'll go yeah I should go home now
were you living what you're gonna leave
no well obviously if I don't have people
to take care of my kids I have to leave
oh you don't have nannies let me tell
you what happened okay so I had a great
woman and she fell in the shower
um but now I kind of have like people
filling in and uh it's kind of
unreliable and I'm dealing with stuff my
dog just died like it's just everything
is colliding right now
I feel like all I ever do is give you
hugs monkey
you're doing the best you can where's
the best place for you is it back home
or is that oh no I don't know I don't
know I don't know
what's going on
what's going on
nothing's going on
all right all right all right all right
all right we need a sniffer [ __ ] for you
that's my medicine I don't know if I
should never like this all right
okay I'm trying I'm not okay
you guys don't know
Lisa needs a stiffer drink
I'm having some issues like like marital
issues you know okay and
I'm just not well right now
I just want to fix everything that's all
you will yeah you'll have the right
mindset sometimes sometimes you need to
step away from things and take a couple
like breaths by yourself so you can get
perspective on the situation things are
going to change things are going to
change every day I promise you I was
married for 21 years I've gone through
every change
nothing these are not going to change
hello skinny margarita super stiff
that's for you
okay I don't know if it's I should be
drinking
I thought planned this I just I just
don't know if my marriage is going to
survive I think it's over
here it's not over unless you want it to
be over if you wanted to be over you
don't have it's not it's not even up to
me
is there anybody else involved because
like yeah where is somebody there's
somebody off the boat I always knew
letty's dating her now he's dating her
that's not okay she's much younger than
you what
what oh my God no she's been lurking
around she's just been off at parties in
my house he's dating her
he's telling me to my face I'm dating
her this is going to be my girlfriend
I'm divorcing you
something is going on
okay so you need to go find a home why
are you in the
kisses
oh my God
this is one of the lowest lows I've ever
experienced in my life
[Music]
foreign
[Music]